i 100
believe in extraterrestrials there is no
doubt anyone who doesn't think that
there isn't life somewhere else in the
universe is at this point
it's a really hard argument to make i
mean the data just shows
that
there are
earth-like planets i i have sort of a
hard time believing that they're here or
they've been here and they're just kind
of
hiding and because in order to do that
you not only have to
not blow yourselves up and become so
advanced that you can create some sort
of technology that is way ahead of where
we are to create faster than light
travel and then i feel like if you pull
that off and you're gonna go all the way
across the universe
you're going to go and like not hide
you're going to be like what's up we're
here we did it i don't buy
this whole they're they're they're all
sneaky why are they sneaky
i'm dan patrick this is the pretty
intense podcast uh today on the show is
josh gates he is a television host and
producer he has a show called expedition
unknown that's on discovery and he also
has a new show called josh gates tonight
and that is how i met him i went on a
show we had a fascinating conversation
and of course i just love traveling and
i love
ancient civilizations and i i just love
learning so he had so much information
because he's been to so many amazing
places in the world and found out that
his background is in two crazy things he
went to school for archaeology and drama
and i was like well dude you have the
perfect job you're on tv
discovering artifacts and learning about
you know the ancient meaning and
significance of all of these crazy
things like mummies and
you know tablets and um ancient sites
and so he really does have the perfect
job he's also a leo and you learn that
really early too and they're usually on
tv so
we just had a blast we talked about
egypt we talked about um the mayan
culture and civilizations and about
pyramids
we talked about
extraterrestrials and perhaps their
interaction
whether or not he believes in them we
also talked about the paranormal
and then he told some crazy stories of
some things that he's experienced in his
life that are like out there and like
wild and make you really think yeah it
was just a really really fun super flowy
conversation with lots of great stories
and
i have a lot of confidence that there's
going to be a lot of you out there that
hear this and then you might be wanting
to tune into expedition unknown or show
tonight as he's just a fascinating guy
with lots of great information so
if you liked the episode please make
sure you hit subscribe and the bell for
notifications when we have a new episode
come out
i love doing this i really really really
love podcasting so just let me know in
the comments what you liked so that we
can make more of it and keep you all
entertained in the meantime enjoy today
i gotta tell you i took a vacation this
summer for the first time in like
literally like 10 years so i have by the
way that would freak people out that you
said that because you're always
traveling i know so okay i'm coming up
on the end of three weeks at my parents
house in massachusetts with my kids and
it has been
blissful and also extremely tiring
children are uh like the greatest
adventure so uh but it has been so great
to like take a little break yeah yeah i
get i've been in indiana with my parents
actually staying with my parents for
seriously two months it's so hot in
arizona where i live so
i just gotta get out of there and i have
two dogs and so
it's way too hot in arizona for my dogs
so
yeah i've been shacking up with my
parents for two months they're uh maybe
they're ready to get rid of me i don't
know maybe they maybe they're used to me
there now but um but there's something
about parents you know yeah it's like
there's something amazing about going
home and you feel like a kid again and
you also feel like a kid again in that
you're still annoyed by your folks and
they're annoyed by you and everyone's
like up at each other's grill every day
and it's hilarious it's amazing it's
like i feel like i'm i'm 44 years old
and i'm also in high school right now at
home with my folks what do they do that
you love though
i just love their routine like my dad
gets up every day at like 4 45 in the
morning for no reason like he has
nowhere to be he has nothing to do it's
like dad thing he gets up he has this
old pickup truck he goes downtown he
hangs out with a bunch of other guys who
get up way too early they sit down at
the dock downtown in their little
seaside town talk about god knows what
you know solve the world's problems he
goes to dunkin donuts he comes back with
some munchkins for the kids you know my
mom is like a professional sunbather at
this point she just sits out and tans
and wears a big funny pink hat i just
love it like they have like this this is
their work life now they they have to
clock in every day for this hilarious
routine
okay that's that's great i do i agree my
parents have the same thing you know
they're in their
you know
early mid 60s and my dad still works and
my dad my mom kind of works she helps
them out but she really watches my
sister's kids a couple days a week and
like they just have their things you
know they're again same thing they're up
at six for no reason right and they're
making coffee and you know i could hear
that because it's not that big of a
house and so you know i can hear the
copy machine go off
and it's there's something really
familiar about it and then of course
when i'm gone i come back to my clothes
being washed and folded and on the bed
which is just magic because i
the best benefit of coming home the
laundry oh man it's the best and and and
so it's really fun oh hi bud hey look at
this pork what's with the cone we've got
a dog here who's eight eating your shirt
and b
has a cone on it's like dug from up what
why does your dog have a comb
actually this is my sister's dog and i
think that um dear sonny got fixed and
so
you know he doesn't have balls to lick
but he he really can't be looking near
where they were
oh tough break buddy tough break yeah
this is but this is how it goes like i
am certain that at some point in this
interview my two children will walk into
this room
like pantless
you know like holding a kitchen knife
like it's mayhem
it'll happen yeah so okay
so you got three weeks off for the first
time like ever um and of course i guess
there's a twist on your um vacation it's
that most people think of vacation they
think i'm going somewhere
and you did kind of go somewhere but you
didn't really take a trip necessarily to
adventure
right it's really like an adventure into
yourself
it is true like people always say like
where do you want to go on vacation i
mean my my my stock answer is i just
love southeast asia like i have a thing
for cambodia vietnam thailand like if i
was gonna snap my fingers and go
somewhere i would i would go to that
part of the world probably and that's
different for everybody you just have
those places you go to where you feel
yeah you're just like oh man what if i
just like sold everything and moved here
and you have these fantasies of like
what if i lived here you know italy is
like that for me too like i could i
could you know move to italy tomorrow
maybe not right now because it's a
million degrees there but um
but no mostly when i have a vacation
i just want to stop moving right now
like you know i i need to
um
to just be still and be in one place
that doesn't last too long like if i'm
anywhere for like a month i get a little
antsy i want to start
travel i start looking at you know
travel websites and stuff but but yeah
it's a vacation for me is not going
anywhere right now i'm wondering if you
still travel as much as you used to i
mean you know i'm sure back in the day i
think you said you know you traveled
like 200 250 days a year is it still
like that it is
through a monkey wrench on everything
but i mean yeah so like covet changed
everything for about a year and a half
for me i mean i went from traveling
you know all the time to not traveling
at all like like everybody um but i was
really fortunate i kept working during
that time i started doing a talk show
for discovery we started kind of limping
out and doing some domestic episodes of
expedition unknown the main show that i
made for them and so we're back now to
traveling and yeah my schedule's still
pretty much full tilt like i i travel
between 200 and 250 days a year
uh i won't do that forever but uh you
know making my show
it's just kind of like we've we have not
been able to figure out a way to make it
quicker because the show is about going
to far-flung places and going to remote
archaeological sites and and having a
real adventure and so
you just can't do that in a few days and
we make quite a lot of episodes of it a
year so it's just one of those things
that no matter how you paper it out it's
just a lot of days abroad so
you know there are days when
um
it's like any job you know like people
always say to me oh you have the best
job in the world i hear that line a lot
and i agree with them like i can't argue
with that like it is such a privilege to
be able to travel you know um no doubt
about it but it is a lot
of nights in weird hotel rooms and
jungle huts and swatting mosquitoes away
so you know it's one of those like be
careful what you wish for jobs so yeah
it's still it's still 200 plus days a
year i still love it uh but it is i do
have to kind of wake up sometimes and do
that affirmation thing of like
remember how rare and special this is
and enjoy this because
you know uh it'll all be gone uh at some
point right and so just soak it in
yeah smart smart it's it's hard in the
moment to
be able to step back and have that
perspective and take it in at the same
time because like you said like you know
when you go on location and you have to
you know do a bunch of voice-overs you
have to do a bunch of you know sort of
like b-roll pieces or you know
certain clips and things that they need
for it's like it becomes work you know
it's not just a flow it's not like
they're just filming you running around
there's a lot of stuff that goes into
having to make like a show
and so it becomes a little bit more work
and it's not always the most glamorous
i'm sure as you're all over the world in
these unique places it's not like you're
like
i think it is right like the minute
you're like i'm a travel host adventure
guy they're like oh my god they think
you're at like the boutique hotels of
the world never yeah i'm like never at
the ritzy places i'm always in some
tumble down because i'm out with these
archaeologists at these at these dig
sites and stuff like every once in a
while i'm in a capital city and we you
know i have an okay hotel but it's like
sometimes i turn on travel channel or
something it'll be a rerun of like
world's greatest pools and i'm like how
do you get that job
you know there is a better job than what
you have oh
i mean in terms of accommodations for
sure my my my job is not winning the
accommodations war yeah okay i'm really
curious because you're so smart you
sound like you just know your [ __ ] do
you have an archaeology archaeology
background do you have a
uh
science and research kind of background
um biology like it's so i have a weird
background like i i grew up um first of
all as like a child of the 80s i grew up
obsessed with
the goonies
raiders of the lost ark
you know temple of doom all those things
i was like you know i was a steven
spielberg kid right so i grew up with
this real love of
adventure
exotic you know treasures and
archaeology and i don't know i just
loved all that stuff from the jump i
think part of that has to do with the
fact that my dad
was a um deep-sea diver he was a
commercial deep-sea diver so super
dangerous job working out in the north
sea in west africa and middle east and
so my dad was always coming back from
these
exotic places so as a kid you know i was
like
yeah that's all i knew i just thought it
was the coolest thing like my dad had
this super cool adventurous life
um i went to school
for i went to tufts university uh here
in massachusetts and i went to i double
majored my poor parents i don't know
god bless them for supporting this i
double majored in archaeology and drama
and i don't know like that's so perfect
for the job i know but like but at the
time it was like what would you ever do
with this you know how on earth is this
going to add up to anything but i loved
archaeology and history and so in
college i majored in that but i also
loved writing and performing and and so
i double majored in drama and
archaeology and
what's weird is how long it took me
after college
to kind of put those together like i i
thought okay i'm going to go to graduate
school for archaeology and become i
wanted to become an underwater
archaeologist i i thought that was going
to be a really that was the field for me
because of my dad's work i love diving i
love the ocean and i thought that's what
i was gonna do but i had been
in massachusetts pretty much my whole
life i grew up here went just went to
college here and i thought i'll go to la
for a few years and try the acting thing
for a bit and the performing thing and
see kind of what that does and then i'll
go to grad school and become an
underwater archaeologist i never quite
made it out of la
but for those first years in la it never
occurred to me to try
hosting or to try to work in this other
field that i was i just saw them as two
separate things yeah and so when i
finally had an opportunity to host a
show that was about traveling and
adventure and archaeology i was like oh
yeah right why didn't i why did i put
these things together earlier so it took
me a while to get there and i i do think
it's a combination of you know like
anything any success it's it's a
combination of hard work and and total
dumb luck and uh
and so
yeah it's one of those things where
i i it took me a long time to get to the
starting line of oh yeah put all this
together have you always loved traveling
yeah my mother is british and so as a
kid we would go to england every year to
visit my my family over there so from an
early age i was kind of going over to
the uk and i and between that and my dad
i kind of had this
this sense of like oh wow there's like a
big world out there you know there's a
lot going on out there and so i always
had an interest in it um and when i got
to la after college i would start
traveling more i'd start i was waiting
tables you know as an actor right so i
was waiting tables and i'd make a little
money and i'd go take a trip and i'd
make a little money and i'd go take a
trip
meanwhile never sort of putting together
that i should professionally attempt to
do these two things it also it was like
before the youtube era so it's like if
it if it was now
i think i'd be like oh i should be a
content creator right like like if i was
born slightly later i think it would
have all snapped earlier because now
you're everyone can become a content
creator right so
but but that wasn't as apparent to me
then
yeah
what's your
sounds geeky what's your sign are you a
sag or a leo or i'm a leo you're a leo
yeah your second guess how did you yeah
and an only child so that i could be a
real jerk if i need to be
that's right it's all about me danica
it's all about me
it's the job the drama comes in because
like leo's are like the quintessential
kind of actor sign because you're always
like an on stage kind of like
influence and uh but sad just love to
travel so i was kind of curious if you
had you might have it more in your chart
i took a couple levels of astrology and
i've heard
from guys that there isn't a girl in the
world that doesn't think about astrology
so i thought i know it's it's it but
it's a funny thing like i think the
other big influence for me though is
like being an only child
only children tend to have to like kind
of make their own fun in a way like they
get more attention and they get more
opportunity from their parents usually
but they kind of have to make up their
own world a little bit so um i think
part of it's that too as a as a kid i
was just kind of like you know you have
to kind of be very imaginative as an
only child yeah yeah okay speaking of
imaginative what's the so is there
always a theme to each season of um
expedition unknown or is it or is it
just kind of or is that only sometimes
so it's by episode right so each episode
is typically about a mystery of some
kind somewhere in the world that we're
gonna tackle and we're looking for shows
that
where there's active work going on you
know like it would it would be unusual
for us to do an hour on
i don't know dragons
you know it's like unless somebody's
digging up dragon bones um we probably
won't won't tackle that so um we want to
go somewhere where something's happening
so we we're looking for shows about
some stories that are big
you know marquee stories you've heard of
the ark of the covenant and the oh my
god speaking of
why do you have it is it there at your
house the ark of the covenant no it's in
um where do they think it is right now
ethiopia ethiopia they think it's in
utopia it's under jerusalem it's in
someone's garage and because you're
watching all that stuff from like like
graham hancock stuff and yeah i you know
i i it's it's a shadowy trail the ark of
the covenant it sort of vanishes off the
map a long long time ago and
who knows where it is what do you what
do you think it is i mean
base level i think there was a box that
was venerated that was kept in the
temple of solomon that was
believed by the hebrews to be the box
that contained
the
broken tablets so the ten commandments
and what else is in there the broken
staff of aaron is in there and some mana
and i you know like whether or not
that's what was in there you know there
are lots of objects that are venerated
that they're like that's that's what
that thing is so yes for sure there was
a a chest that was in that temple um and
that temple was destroyed and jerusalem
was sacked and was then resacked and you
know i mean over the history of
jerusalem is like
you know um
the babylonians are here and the
arabs are here and the christians are
here and then the arabs are here again
and you know i mean it's like it goes
back and forth and back and forth and so
um
you know where does it go in all of that
i don't know it's a pretty shadowy trail
um there are
these whisperings oh maybe it went here
maybe it went back to
babylon maybe it maybe it was hidden
underneath the city of jerusalem there's
a whole tradition that says oh it went
to ethiopia
um you know i'm sure that it was
considering it was it was believed to be
this incredibly holy thing
unless it just ended up under a pile of
rubble you know like in a in a
building collapse or something it
probably was squirreled away off
somewhere
to me that the challenge with the ark is
like there just isn't enough of a paper
trail it's like you just don't i mean it
could be anywhere
yeah and if it was i mean we we have
descriptions from the bible of what it
what it looked like but you know if it
was wooden if it was made of some
organic material and i mean who knows
you know i mean it might be i mean i've
been very curious about it isn't there a
lot of
um
theories on the fact that the arc kind
of fits perfectly into let's say the the
what would be maybe a sarcophagus they'd
call it in the king's chamber in the
great pyramid it actually like the
dimensions fit correctly inside of that
and that like isn't there some some sort
of mystery around like a blue mist
energy
where the ark has been
um i mean there and then why does
everyone why did people get sick around
it too because there's stories and old
stories about people not wanting to be
around the ark because it would it was
killing people well power god type stuff
i mean this is the kind of like
you know this is this is the
the thing about the ark and it's the
thing about
you know there there are a number of
things like the arc that people just
kind of
um graft onto
and and the the the great pyramid is is
like this as well these objects or these
constructions that are
so mystical to people that
that that kind of your head spins and
people concoct a lot of theories about
what they are and how they were built
and what they were used for you know
it's it's like it's tough i mean the ark
is
at its core
it's a symbol of god it's a symbol of
god you know his his commandments his
power um his presence and and bringing
that presence into the holy land so it's
like it is this incredibly important
symbol
for uh both the jewish and christian
faiths and
at the same time it may be you know it
probably was a real object and so
i think when you have this intersection
between a physical thing and something
that is mystical
then suddenly we concoct a lot of ideas
about it i mean i personally
see the ark as something that probably
did exist and probably is gone forever
you know i mean i think it is a it is
there's just no
could somebody open some chamber
underneath jerusalem one day under the
walls of jerusalem and fi i mean it's
not impossible
um it certainly is a very particular
looking object the way that that it's
described with these angel wings and
these you know um
on top but i but i if i was a betting
man i would say the ark is vanished into
the pages what the hell are you going on
an expedition for
that's a good question
um that's a great question but you know
this is this is kind of what the show's
about it's like it's kind of about this
exact conversation which is like
we all know the ark most of us know it
from you know um temple or sunday school
or indiana jones
what's the deal with the ark right i
mean that's that's that is kind of also
at the core of of our show is this
exploration of what's the real deal with
object x or with mystery y right so
we'll go looking for for things where
there's a story that you know or you
think you know and then we get into well
what's what's real or what can we really
say you know we're doing a show right
now on moses speaking of the ark um
we're doing a show on uh mysteries of
moses and the ark is part of that but
but only sort of tangentially really but
there's this other big thing which is
like
was moses a real person like is there a
historical moses like was there a guy
who genuinely was raised
with the pharaoh in egypt right figured
out he was hebrew uh or or that he was a
semite figured out that that he was not
an egyptian saw the these egyptian
slaves being mistreated and said let my
people go we're getting out of here
we're going to the holy land like did
any of that really historically happen
right so that's a huge difficult
question and so it's really fun to go
and meet with really smart people who
are archaeologists and egyptologists and
historians who can shed light on
on those questions because
you know we think about these these
characters uh and and we don't often
think like okay if there was a moses
like where's he buried and there are
multiple places that claim to be the
tomb of moses in the world and i mean
[ __ ] we don't even know where jesus is
really buried well there we go so
another question is he could be in
another big huge you know difficult
question is like i mean there's a theory
he might be in india
yeah the other day somebody emailed me
this whole thing about the life of jesus
in india you know so exactly
these are the fascinating things that we
dig into are these questions of like
looking at these stories and figuring
out not just fact from fiction but but
like
what does the archaeological record show
what does history show um and it's tough
because
look i mean whenever you deal with
especially things like the arc or moses
or jesus you're you're treading into an
area of faith too so so yeah it's also
this question of like you have to be
really cautious and diplomatic about how
you approach those things yeah well what
about something really important to a
lot of people what about the burning
bush do you think that he was just high
[Music]
um
you know
there's theories on that too this is a
weird thing like in in the story of
moses
there's a lot of really wild
supernatural stuff happening like there
are these bushes that are burning that
are talking there are staffs that are
turning i don't know have you ever been
high before sometimes a bush might talk
to you right there are these plagues
these i mean
this whole situation in in the story of
moses where moses says to the pharaoh
look let my people go or god is really
gonna you know whoop you and pharaoh's
like yeah no i don't think so and god
unleashes these horrendous plagues on
egypt that are you know like rivers
turning to blood and boils and lice
yeah i mean all sorts of horrible stuff
and then the last of these plagues that
the tenth plague is like the nastiest of
all which is that god is gonna kill
every first-born egyptian son he's going
to kill all these babies right so like
this is like really like the story of
moses is
is is kind i mean i again i don't mean
to be disrespectful to it religiously
but just narratively it's like an action
movie like it is like a hollywood
blockbuster which is why it was a
hollywood blockbuster because it is like
this incredible story of supernatural
good versus evil and you know you've got
these villains and the pharaoh and and
this reluctant hero and moses like the
whole thing is just like a movie it's
this great story so i'm really excited
to dig into it on the show because
it is one of those things where like we
all know this character everyone knows
moses everyone knows that name
who is he who was he was he you know did
he exist so that's that's the show in a
nutshell so fascinating i love all that
stuff because i'm so fascinated with um
with i don't here's the weird thing i
remember being in fifth grade and asking
my what was called social studies then i
remember asking my social studies
teacher
yes annika what's the point of learning
about history like i just didn't
care get it
like to me
i'd i like ancient history i've learned
but i don't like more like modern day i
don't like world war history
um that kind of stuff but ancient
history ancient civilizations and an
ancient history of mystery around it
which the older it is the more mystery
there is um i find to be really
fascinating because i feel like
it's
it's clues to how to like
our reality and what we really what pure
potential could be because you've been
to so many amazing places like how in
the hell did they build the pyramid like
the original question right and so once
you finally
you know if you could ever get that
answer then all of a sudden
you know things open up in a new way
because surely it's not with
whatever we thought they had back then
and if that's the case then we can step
into the next phase of growth and
evolution and through awareness and so
why do you care like why do you care
about all of these um ancient cities or
um all of these stories and all of the
all of the mystery what is it that you
why do you give a [ __ ]
it's such a great question um
i don't know for for me i think it's a
couple different things one of them is
kind of a spooky thing which is that
sometimes at these sites like ancient
egypt's a great example rome is a great
example
the maya i love the maya i'm big into
them um
sometimes you go to these
ancient capitals these ancient cities
and you look at
how
together these people were like they had
government sorted out engineering sorted
out mathematics um they're they're
feeding huge amounts of people they have
civilization they're making art they are
um
you know forging ahead in science like
they've got the world figured out and it
all falls apart and crumbles to nothing
and so part of it for me is like
when you stand in these places i get
kind of a chill of like
this could be us this may be us like we
may be the next thing that's that's like
this and there is this weird echo of the
past of like
how did they mess it all up
and what what should we kind of remember
about why they messed it all up because
a lot of these civilizations really had
their act together you know and and and
it's it's this fascinating thing and i
think you know coveted was kind of like
this where it's like
there was this moment where we sort of
realized oh wait a minute like the world
can just kind of reach out and smack you
a tsunami a plague a a massive natural
disaster a meteor you know impacting the
planet this this idea that we're just
living our lives and everything is
permanent and and civilization is here
no like it can all go away
tomorrow in the middle of this interview
like it can all vanish right so
i don't know that's part of it for me is
the idea of like
the the sort of
the achievement of these civilizations
and then how they just completely
disintegrate is fascinating but i also
kind of get fascinated on a personal
level by them like where you
you meet
i mean meat is a weird word but like you
meet people you meet skeletons and
remains of people and you look at them
face to face and you're like this was a
person this was like you know history is
so sometimes it's so impersonal because
we're talking about huge events so we
don't kind of go down to that
microscopic level of like this dude this
guy this person and sometimes when
you're at a dig site
you know we were just in egypt uh at an
excavation in saqqara which is this big
and we were there when they opened this
little wooden coffin of this little girl
who was probably like eight or nine
years old
and
you know her mummy was really badly
preserved but she had this beautiful
necklace on and these beautiful earrings
and you could see that she'd been kind
of laid in there with care and she'd
been dressed up and she would have
looked beautiful i'm sure when she was
you know mummified and and you just sort
of think this was a little kid who had
such a short little life but she was
somebody's daughter she was part of a
family and like all of that is just sort
of gone and there's something even
though it's a little bit um
you know um
it's a little scary to think about but
it's like you you sort of think about
your place in this universe and like you
know we're all gonna end up uh
you know um where where she is at some
point and so if there's there's
something about connecting to the past i
think that feels important to me because
if you just sort of ignore it
um
yeah i think you're missing out on a big
a big part of of
our collective kind of world you know so
i i don't know but the short dumb answer
is
um i just think it's cool you know i
mean i just think going to these sites
is cool and i and i could roam around in
these ruins and ask questions of someone
much smarter than me all day because
it's just cool what has it taught you
then if you're looking at i'm just
thinking about you know you you speaking
about this you know little girl that was
mummified and taken care of and and like
there was such
because i mean i've explored some of
these places and there was such
intention with like everything
and such detail and care
and um
yeah significance to so many things even
the small things and and i think to
myself like just in that example of
someone getting buried and mummified and
putting jewelry on them like how does it
happen today some people get you know
some people are cremated some people you
know put in this box and they're given
their favorite sweater and whatever but
like
it's not mummified it's not you know all
their nicest jewelry it's not being
buried in a gigantic
uh tomb that is
adorned like everywhere every every
single inch of it with
stories about who they were and now not
everyone this is more of the pharaohs
and the high priests and priestesses and
people like that um queens but but the
look at how they were adorned and now i
think like look at what are they going
to think about someone that died now in
2022
and how that was taken care of and i'm
just kind of curious your thoughts when
you put when putting that in perspective
and then thinking to what it is that you
have learned and your takeaway from
visiting these places and experiencing
them
i i think when you look back through
history you see
that there is a focus that people have
on power
on
authority on wealth you see a lot of
that obviously and you see
these civilizations that expand beyond
their reach
that like they want more and more and
more and eventually it all falls apart
because they're too big
uh or they can't keep the peace and
other power players come in and you know
it all goes to hell that way uh but
i think a big thing like the maya are
really interesting to me and there's a
site that i'm really obsessed with um
that i talk a lot about because i just
kind of can never get it out of my head
it's a place called el mirador and it's
uh and it's a maya site in northern
guatemala right near the border of
mexico so it's up near where tikal is in
in northern guatemala and um without
boring anybody the the maya
there's this thing called the
pre-classic maya and then the classic
maya and basically what happens is like
the mayas show up and everything's kind
of great and they build this big
civilization and then the entire thing
collapses and it collapses
like down to zero like their language
collapses everything just goes
completely away it is a complete and
total apocalypse and then they reignite
and they kind of start over and that's
the classic so there's this big question
like what what happened to this
pre-classic maya like why did they flame
out so badly down to ashes that they had
to rebuild everything and restart
everything and at el mirador which is
this big pre-classic maya capital it's
this huge mega city out in the jungle of
guatemala you go there and
first of all it is about as indiana
jonesy as sight as you can get it is
just deep in the jungle you can trek
there but it's miserable and it takes
days through the swamps there's no road
out to it or you can helicopter in and
you fly over jungle and jungle and
jungle and then there's a tiny little
area cut out to land a helicopter and
then you're just engulfed in this jungle
on the ground and there's just pyramids
and temples everywhere as far as you can
see
so the city is roughly the size of los
angeles if that is i mean which is
insane right like this place is this is
like the
megalopolis of
ancient you know mesoamerican world so
it's like the karnak of uh yeah exactly
this gigantic gigantic place and there
are
um these huge constructions there the
main pyramid there
called ladonta may be
uh the biggest pyramid in the world by
volume it's not the tallest it's not as
tall as the great pyramid of giza but it
may be wider it is wider at the base so
it may be by volume the biggest pyramid
in the world
it's barely excavated this whole site i
mean um it's just this incredible place
and when you go there and you learn
about them and you learn about kind of
why this all fell apart for them the the
theme that comes up a lot is this
concept of the conspicuous consumption
of resources which basically means
they just started using everything in
this jungle around them in ways they
didn't need to
but they just thought looked cooler or
were a little more luxe or just you know
better
they they they started paving everything
with this
kind of white limestone plaster that
looks a lot like plaster in your house
like it's it's legit plaster it's made
from crushed up limestone in order to
in order to make it you have to burn a
lot of wood like a lot of trees and
green trees that turn hotter
so you have to burn down lots of forest
to make this stuff
and they started plastering everything
with this with this stuff because it
just looked cool it looked nice better
than walking around on dirt right
and as they started doing this they just
started chopping down and chopping down
this forest and what ended up happening
to them at el mirador it looks like
is something that they just couldn't
have predicted which is that not so much
that they deforested it but that like
the trees the roots of these trees were
kind of holding back this mud
that ended up kind of steeping into
their water that ended up making it
harder to grow crops that ended up sort
of poisoning their food supply it's one
of those like butterfly effect things
wow where they just sort of thought hey
we're the masters of this domain we can
do whatever we want to this ecosystem
it'll support us we're the best
and the environment kind of
you know we don't totally understand our
environment right because it's made up
of billions of life forms that are all
interacting in this crazy ecosystem and
so um they tipped the balance in a way
that
they fell apart they ended up not being
able to eat and like you know food like
even though it sounds boring the
capacity to feed people is a big deal
and it's a big deal in the ancient world
and food supply is something that we
could totally take for granted in the
modern world we kind of shouldn't
because we just think the supermarket's
always going to have stuff in it but if
things get really bad that won't be seen
right so yeah
that's right so um you know like
civilizations can fall apart if they
just keep doing more and more and more
and i think
getting back long-windedly to your
question what are people going to think
when they see us i think they're going
to marvel at weirdly i know this is like
a strange answer i just think they're
going to be so
blown away by the amount of plastic
i just think they're going to look
because this plastic is going to be
around forever like they're going to
find plastic you know bottle caps and
soda rings and stuff forever
and if we all go to ashes they're just
going to
much as the ancient world is all about
pottery that's their plastic that's the
plastic of the ancient world everything
was carried around in these ceramic jugs
people are just going to be like oh this
is a classic this is this type of bottle
this type of thing and i think they're
going to kind of wonder why we
because we know it's bad right like we
know all that stuff is like not great
and we know it's it i mean nobody even
people who aren't particularly
environmentally motivated they kind of
know that plastics are like not great
right but we just don't really seem to
care that much and by the way i'm not up
on some pedestal here i went and bought
my kids these like eight packs of like
you know apple juice things that are
like you drink them in two sips and then
you throw them in the garbage the little
mini individual things that thing will
be in a landfill for like hundreds of
years my kid drank it in seven seconds
you know yeah you just think like why
are like
why are we doing this and the answer is
because it's convenient right and we
like it so i don't know part of what i
think they're going to say about us is
man we burned pretty bright like we we
just were real consumers like we loved
making and buying things
so i think that's dangerous yeah i'm
also as guilty as anybody of it so i'm
really i've really wondered many times
if um
if really
i'm gonna start here and then we'll grow
the idea um if we just kind of come and
go evolutionary as humans like some
variation of human kind of just comes
and goes and it's just we're like an
ecosystem to the planet
like it's just you know you just get too
big you get too greedy
whatever it is and earth swallows you up
and says let's start again and we can
continue on with that but what do you
think about that idea and is there any
evidence that shows that yeah i mean i
do think if you if you look at you know
the evolution of species it's like you
you cut it or you don't you compete and
if you don't make it you don't make it i
mean there's no question that like
we could as a species like the most
obvious game and ender for us right is
nuclear war right so we as a species
could uh
get to such a point where somebody
finally pushes one of these buttons
because there are these you know these
these um
weapons all over the world and we could
go and have a uh a nuclear war which
would uh not only kill a lot of people
what would poison a lot of the planet
and i don't think humanity would be
erased but it would be like a you know
biblical setback um and we would
probably have to kind of
become you know scrape our way out of
the ashes and start over i mean yeah i
think that what about going into earth
what about going inner earth then to
hide from it and what about what about
what about inner earth people no there's
no inner earth people
you've been watching you're watching
king kong movies too much well yeah i am
watching king kong and all kinds of
other crazy stuff on youtube i love i
mean we can build a bunch of
shelters and live down there and life
would be pretty miserable
i mean what's the difference between
that and like inner earth i mean like if
you have to go inside the earth to wait
out the storm why didn't couldn't
somebody else have done that yeah but
there's no sunlight down there there's
no food like how do you grow anything
how do you get what if they have their
own arc and the arc makes some light
sanica i am proposing many crazy things
because i love to get a reaction
and hear what takes what gets traction
you know if you think there's a bunch of
morlocks hanging around down there
walking around in their secret
underground chambers
to me first of all let's just think
about it this way if you were one of
these underground people who the hell
would want to live underground why
wouldn't you just come up through a
sewer grate and be like enough of this i
want to be out here where it's sunny i
think the teenage mutant ninja turtles
did that right yeah i mean
i am
i just think
that
yes to answer your first question yeah
the earth can swallow us up like the
bugs that we are and and yeah and i
think that and and kovalev i think was a
little bit of a wake-up call that like
you can have
especially because of how globalized we
are now in air travel and we just are
constantly in each other's right every
day thousands of people are crossing
borders millions of people are crossing
borders so um
yeah a a plague um a weapon a bio weapon
a nuclear weapon yeah like we are not we
are not
any safer from extinction than
okay somebody else or the dinosaurs a
meteor could hit the planet okay let's
hop skip and jump to another crazy idea
because you've you've done some stuff
around it but um
extraterrestrials i mean
okay here's my take
i 100
believe in extraterrestrials there is no
doubt anyone who doesn't think that
there isn't life somewhere else in the
universe is at this point
it's a really hard argument to make i
mean the data just shows
that
there are
earth-like planets there are planets
that sit in this sweet spot in other
solar systems of course there are right
and those conditions of
sunlight and an atmosphere
you know we know things will grow so i
mean i just
think that
as each day march is on you it's just
becoming clearer and clearer that the
probability is just overwhelming that
there's life in the universe
whether it's been here and is like
skulking around in the shadows i am much
more skeptical about now there are
things that i have seen
some of these videos these navy videos
that show these high speed i mean i
don't know what they are i don't have
all the answers there's just something
to me
a little i i have sort of a hard time
believing that they're here or they've
been here and they're just kind of
hiding and
taking cows and testing on them and
stuff i don't know i just it it does
seem like
i guess my theory is that life exists in
the universe but it is rare like it's i
mean rare meaning you have to travel a
long way to find it
so i would think that if given the fact
that there are like trillions of
galaxies or billions yeah so so like
maybe not rare mathematically but
probably rare
that any one species could ever reach
another right that because in order to
do that you not only have to
not blow yourselves up and become so
advanced that you can create some sort
of technology that is way ahead of where
we are to create faster than light
travels so you you have to you you have
to get off the planet you mean the stuff
that we're talking about right now
getting off the planet you mean stuff
that we're doing right now yeah but but
like but but to reach another planet of
people we are so far from that baby
steps man we're like
but that's what i'm saying like you
gotta hang around long enough that you
don't get wiped out by
another civilization a meteor a plague
of whatever you you have to survive long
enough to become that advanced and then
i feel like if you pull that off and
you're gonna go all the way across the
universe
you're gonna go and like not hide you're
gonna be like what's up we're here we
did it i don't buy
this whole they're they're they're all
sneaky why are they sneaky
why are aliens sneaky
because they're different and we'd freak
out
like what would you do if you saw if you
saw even if you saw like bigfoot
or
like something crazy that we don't know
if really exists but maybe and and this
is like within our psyche even and if
you saw it and it kind of resembles this
and that and you put them together and
you're like oh you'd still freak the
hell out you'd still be like this is
legitimate you run or you'd shoot it and
you'd test it yes
right this is the sort of childhood's
end or like this is like a star trek
thing this is this is the prime
directive in star trek you don't mess
with the civilization with it with a
planet that's more primitive than you
because it will totally alter their
development because they'll start
worshiping you or trying to kill you or
whatever i guess that's sound thinking i
mean i'm a big star trek fan so i i get
it
but i just kind of think
i don't know i just haven't seen
anything
compelling enough to have me say
yes that's what i think is happening
stop it you've been to like all of these
crazy places in the world that you can't
explain how things were built and how
they had the technology and why is it so
perfect and why is it
astrologically aligned in such
perfection why does this why does
stonehenge line up perfectly with the
solstice like why do all these things
exist like did they really have the
technology
i'm giving these ancient people more
credit
i i think that it is remarkable what you
can do
if you are laser focused on it like
you know people talk about
i mean stonehenge okay yeah stonehenge
is astronomically fascinating but like
look at it it's pretty
like homespun it's a bunch of blocks
that are kind of like they're megalithic
stones i know but like but it's not like
some laser cut alien like hundreds of
miles away
i know but i think they rolled them on
wood on logs really
let me tell you something never this is
this is my one big counter argument to
uh people who believe in like alien
intervention stuff never underestimate
the ability to do difficult things if
you don't have much else to do
i'm serious like if you're in egypt
you're like okay i'm the pharaoh um it's
a million degrees i got the nile we're
making food things are happening i'm a
i'm a you know egomaniac uh i want a
giant thing built uh and i'm the pharaoh
so everybody's gonna you know either i'm
gonna pay this workforce or i'm gonna
enslave people that's a big debate but i
think that most of it are like workers
and it's like nobody has anything else
to do
build me this thing
i mean look what taylor swift did with
the pandemic man she made some albums
she got busy she got busy this is what
i'm saying that's her stonehenge
i'm telling you if you have nothing else
to do
you can do a lot
and if you have enough people
all of these places where there's
pyramids and giant constructions they
never it's not like they're happening in
places where nobody's around there with
these huge population centers where it's
like these people need something to do
we're going to put them on this pyramid
project
so you've been to egypt you know the
nile you've been on the nile i've been
on the nile you've been down to aswan
you've been you've been to probably the
quarry where they supposedly got all of
their stones like i have two and you're
like oh here and then you think oh
okay it's going on boats
have you seen those boats they don't
look real shut they don't look real
sharp and then you think to yourself and
how did they even get the big stones
onto the boat like it just does not make
sense
it it you danica you've got to give them
more credit i can't i won't i i know
what people i won't do it human nature
to do the minimum back then they could
have just like sailed off into the
desert when you go to these quarries
um the big one is down at silsilla which
is this cool egyptian quarry
there are like obelisk
shaped
notches missing from the walls like
they're clearly popping huge blocks out
of these walls right and
we know
that
not all of them made it like there's big
chunks of blocks in the bottom of the
nile like our boat didn't work right
like you can see that they're trying
stuff and they're moving things and by
the way
when you went to egypt you probably saw
the bent pyramid they messed up a
pyramid they got halfway up and they
were like ah [ __ ] and then they had to
change the angle on it so like you can
see that they're working on it but i'm
telling you i'm sticking with my theory
which is
if you don't have much to do you can do
a lot
what have you done the last three weeks
nothing
to see have kept my children alive
that's difficult that's actually always
hard
i mean you're in the ocean here that's
the constant threat of drama my my
sister's little girl has a shiner and
i'm like you know it's just you know
what happens you know she's two years
old every day that guy and you're like
yeah it is whatever
like if social services got to look at
my kids like they're covered in bruises
and cuts and scrapes and splits
sweatshirts and sweatpants for for the
kids every day every day i gotta hide it
yeah no they're just they're living
their their little lives they're testing
things out and when you test things out
much like the band pyramid you fall down
sometimes have you ever had any like
super scary moments in any of these
places that you've gone where you
thought um
you know this is all fun and games until
you're about to
you know like fit like physically or
like
actually kind of anything i mean maybe
there's been something physical or
something and that has endangered but
also if there's anything like spooky
scary like you know you opened up the
door to a tomb and all of a sudden you
know you saw a ghost fly out and you're
like holy [ __ ] like physically a bunch
of stuff i mean i knock on wood all the
time that like my crew and i have done
as well as we have but like yeah all
sorts of
of things i mean i have spent the last
15 years flying in the sketchiest planes
and helicopters and cars and i mean you
know so
um i was in an airplane once in romania
that the roof ripped off of during
flight what
yeah it was an old russian plane and we
were flying in romania and i was in the
cockpit and we were filming and the roof
peeled off like a cannon
and like
i would say scary but i know i always
say to people like if you're in a plane
and then suddenly you're outdoors like
that's not good
that's very good i hope you weren't hot
very high up because pressurization i
think is important we were not thank god
um and it was a non-pressurized plane so
um you thought you were asking for a
convertible exactly exactly um uh we've
had that have we've had a lot of run-ins
with wildlife at el mirador at that maya
site yeah i was sitting doing an
interview with an archaeologist on this
temple step and my camera guy just
started screaming snake snake snake and
we turned and there was a fertile ants
which is this very dangerous snake um in
uh in central america that uh
that was just cruising down this stair
aggressively coming at us and you know
jumped up and jumped out of the way and
we've had a lot of run-ins like that of
like snakes and scorpions and you know
spiders and things like that
that are
you know you just
you'll walk down a trail five times with
a crew and then the sixth time you look
and there's like a pit viper and a tree
and you go man we walked past that five
times yeah you and bear grylls should do
a show going to all the doing getting to
scary places he could help
bear grylls is is legit man he you know
i'm uh i'm a
world travel and adventure guy he is a
legit survivalist i think bear girls
would would eat me for lunch in terms of
uh you know being out in the woods for
the night but we did eat a scorpion
together so yeah you're right and he
told story he's told this other story
about he uh to stay hydrated one time he
had he got a snake and he kept the snake
skin and he peed in the snake skin and
then he like
kept it and then drank it later i mean
that's the big difference between bear
and i he's much more interested in
drinking urine than i am i think he's a
bit more interested in drinking your own
it comes up a lot weirdly it's uh
yeah that's not uh it's not i'm not as
interested in that anything freaky
anything shock you or take you like
totally off guard that you know because
look you were talking about el niro door
and how you know it's
it's less known than let's say egypt but
it's not no less shocking and amazing
and and awe-inspiring and so maybe and
you talk about like who writes the
history books it's like the the victors
do and who wrote these stories so there
might be places out there that are like
holy crap how do we not know about this
i've had a few so like the very first
series that i hosted was a show called
destination truth and it was on sci-fi
it was kind of what i call an uggabooka
show so we would go around the world and
we would investigate legends and
mysteries and paranormal stuff and i
always was very honest on the show that
i was a kind of
a paranormal
agnostic that it was sort of like i i'm
happy to go look for ghosts in this
place that you say is incredibly haunted
and i'm into it and i kind of like i
want to see a ghost i mean i don't want
it to hurt me but like
who wouldn't want some validation of the
other side right so um but i don't
really know that i'm going to that was
always my approach and so i went to a
lot of really
scary places on that show
and spent the night in a lot of scary
places
and
you know it's this weird thing of like
there are places
that
have
a vibe
i'm not a very like
i'm not an overly kind of
spiritual person but i there are places
right but there are places that i will
say and i would say this to any hardened
skeptic that there are places that you
walk into that have a vibe they have an
energy i have no idea what that is
um but i don't think it's just my mind
kind of saying oh this is a spooky place
there are just places you there are
people's houses you walk into that are
perfectly nice houses and you walk in
and you go ugh i don't want to be here
and there are places that you walk into
where you feel
an incredible sense of relaxation or joy
and it may and it's not necessarily some
incredibly beautiful place like there
aren't just places that kind of seem to
emote something and so yeah there are
places that i went to i mean there's we
used to go to these abandoned insane
asylums and hospitals and stuff there's
a place called waverly hills you know
that place i feel like i've heard of
that terrifying is that they've probably
done uh they've probably done a um
they've done a bunch of ghost shows
there it's terrifying yeah yeah posted a
um the the show ghost hunters did a live
show there which i hosted i wasn't
really participating in and i was just
kind of the host and i had to move
around throughout the night to different
kind of host locations to tonight
through the night oh you were there at
night and i just
hated it i hated walking around there
alone i had my binder and my notes and
i'd have to go from one side of the
property to the other and i kept
thinking to myself what are you afraid
of like
you're you're you're grown man you're
just walking there's lots of people kind
of around i was so spooked out by that
place it just had the worst
energy
and there are there are a couple of
times in my life where i've had an
experience that i truly can't explain
one was we did an episode of destination
truth in china
at this section of the great wall of
china which was known as the wild wall
and it's this area where there's all
these ghost stories about the wall and
it's reportedly this very haunted area
and we were there
and we used to wear these kind of goofy
backpacks on that show which had camera
equipment attached to them and a kind of
a swing arm that would come around to
film your face
so these little kind of ghostbuster
packs that that back in the day had
actual like mini dv decks on them and
stuff was like all on you like uh it was
all on your back and the camera could
film you so you kind of yeah independent
roving got it right and every hour or so
though they had the camera guys would
have to get behind you and change out
the batteries and the mini dvd tables
right so you kind of stand there and
they jostle you around a little bit and
they try to get the door open on the
thing
and i remember standing on this section
of the wall and it was an hour was up
and we were going to change my tapes and
my camera guy was behind me and he was
changing all the stuff in the backpack
and really moving me around kind of
roughly like he couldn't get something
open
and i turned over my shoulder to ask him
something and there was nobody there and
he was 50 feet away
and it was the only time in my life that
i ever felt physically moved by
something yeah and then of course i
spent the next
you know week in my head going
was it one of those things where i
thought somebody was behind me so
psychologically i felt like i was being
moved and i was like no i was being like
manhandled
yeah it wasn't like subtle either
because you were telling the story not
subtle at all aggressive so it's not
even just like you kind of felt
something and maybe you could
manufacture that in your head this was
like what the heck is that right so i
don't know and then another time we were
at a place in japan called the suicide
forest which is a place
yeah it's all ready
for
exactly bring the kids
it's this forest in japan where people
will go to commit suicide it's become
like a popular suicide destination and
where is this again it's in
japan it's called
i think i've heard i think i've watched
some stories about that it's one of
those that you don't want to go in
yeah i mean it's a very very
weird place and um
and so we were there overnight and of
course akigahara is the name of it and
it's also known as the sea of trees in
the northwestern flank of mount fuji so
i i kept in my head i kept thinking
i do not want to run into an actual
person who's hanged themselves here and
that can happen there like it happens
so i kept thinking like that was my big
fear it's like i really don't want to
suddenly be in like a real horror film
here you know
and
i thought i saw
more than out of the corner of my eye
like i thought i saw in the woods with
me somebody standing very close to me
off to my right a woman and
it like i could see her like somebody
was there and then she just wasn't
and
i at the time was like that's your brain
that's like you were so worked up about
the possibility of seeing something that
you matrixed in some thing and you had a
weird waking hallucination or did i i
don't know but i know that i thought i
saw someone in those woods for a second
and then they were gone so that kind of
stuff
stays with you so the and then to me the
other the final kind of like weird
spiritual thing that's happened to him i
mean i've been in lots of spooky places
where i thought i heard things and
we saw things on thermal imagers that i
can't explain i mean that happened a lot
to me but none of them kind of
sent me like
over the edge into like you know full
scale like paranormal
the the other thing is i think we might
have mentioned this when you when you
came on my show is is ayahuasca
yeah um uh i did ayahuasca on on
my expedition unknown we did we did a
series about the afterlife a few years
ago and we filmed an ayahuasca ceremony
with me in in peru how'd that go
it was uh have you done it did i ask you
this
in peru it was um
it was incredible it was the longest
night of my life
well it was a long journey it was a long
journey and um parts of it were
absolutely beautiful parts of it were
really scary it was kind of all the
above
and um
but
it was the kind of thing where when it
was over
the next day and even now like it really
has stayed with me i think about it you
can't forget yeah forget right yeah and
and i kind of was left with kind of two
thoughts which is that either
i had an experience that was totally
external to me like it was spiritual i
went somewhere else i actually had this
experience it was real right either that
which if that's true that's mind-blowing
right for me personally that's like holy
[ __ ] i saw
the mysteries of the universe right oh
you name it i mean like beings and alien
ships and so you're wondering did i go
off planet did i go did i go and like
either come like to some other dimension
okay with whatever um
or
it's all in your head it's a chemical
reaction it happened in your brain it's
all in your head and if that's true
that's also crazy because it just
reveals
that our minds the power of our brain
is so mysterious to us right that like
we don't actually this entire thing this
entire reality in front of us like put
aside the spiritual thing let's pretend
there's none of that let's just pretend
it's all chemicals right
it just means that
what you think is happening around you
your perception of the world it's just
this
thing that your brain is making and
telling you that here's what's in front
of it it's just signals coming into your
eyes and your brain is like here's
what's there
and your brain can alter that and change
that and then you kind of go well wait a
minute what's real and what is reality
and what the heck am i and then your
brain kind of breaks and you go welcome
to my number one question i think about
every day yeah so
to me that was like my big takeaway from
ayahuasca is that either i had a genuine
spiritual experience or
my brain is so untrustworthy and full of
mystery and either way it's like
it's amazing right either way it's truly
amazing well did it did it i mean it
sounds like it had a long-term effect
because you say you can't forget so
what is uh what was the
the learning or how did it change your
life
it did you know i mean i it's people ask
me i i should preface the answer by
saying people ask me if i recommend
doing it and i say
that in some ways i'm more scared of it
now that i've done it
because i my experience with drugs prior
to ayahuasca was
fairly limited i mean i'd been stoned
and i'd taken mushrooms in in college
you know but but i i hadn't really done
heavy-duty hallucinogens like that that
was not in my resume and so
i i wasn't totally prepared for how
transportative it was
i sort of thought because people say oh
sometimes you see snakes and spiders and
creepy crawlies like that that happens
on iowa and mother ayahuasca as a snake
nature imagery right and so i thought
okay josh what's the worst that can
happen you're in this hut and a snake is
gonna come in here that you're gonna
hallucinate a snake coming into this hut
and you can get through that you know
that that's as bad as it as it's gonna
be because it can't hurt you it's not
there
what i wasn't prepared for is that i
wasn't in the hut
like i left the building right so like i
now that i know
that sections of it can be that powerful
that you can sort of actually go
somewhere um now i'm more now i'm like
oh my god anything could have happened
it could have been a because some people
take it and they have truly horrendous
experiences and some people take it and
they have cosmic experiences that change
their lives for the better did you just
do it once
i did it once
i know some people go for like a week i
just can't imagine yeah i mean every
time is different you know yeah i know
every time is different and everyone
tells you there's going to be good
nights and bad nights and all that stuff
so when i say to when people say to me
should i do it i go i don't know like
i saw things that were very scary i saw
things that were really beautiful but i
also
now that i know
what it can be
yeah i think you could have a total
jacob's ladder nightmare experience
where you spend six to eight nine hours
yeah in an absolute psychological
torture chamber so do you think it gave
you because the saying would be it gives
you doesn't give you what you want it
gives you what you need do you feel like
it gave you what you need and then i'm
going to continue on and say you've got
all the skepticism of like
extraterrestrial and ghosts and all you
know there's like a skepticism beyond
what you can see and all you did was see
a bunch of that stuff so
i know so i i do sort of think it gave
me i mean look we i we were making a
show about the afterlife so
when they said
for people who don't know when you when
you do these ayahuasca ceremonies you
are asked usually to have an intention
or a question or something that you want
to ask mother ayahuasca this you know
this this um
sort of spiritual plant medicine energy
medicine right so
and they will also tell you as you just
said it doesn't always give you the
answer that you want it might give you
what you need which might not be the
thing you think you want um and so
i kind of went in there with two
different things
one was for the show and one was for me
personally the one for the show was what
happens when we die we're here to talk
about the afterlife so i want to
understand the afterlife that's why i'm
here that's the show that we're making
this is called the vine of death it is
supposed to connect us to this
other world this natural realm what's
there
and then i had a personal intention
which was
much more about
me and my kids and my career in my life
which is that i have these two young
children i travel for an enormous part
of the year i want to be a good father i
want to be a successful
you know person at my at my career
how do i do all this and balance the
world and that that was kind of my
personal intention going in so i got
none of that
none of it what happened
how many years ago was this
um
maybe two or three years ago three years
life changed at all in the last two or
three years yeah but but but what one of
the things that they also said to me was
you know
one of the ways in which the the the
experience can be quite unpleasant is if
you try to force things like never fight
it just yeah you probably won't have
much of an experience if you do that
actually right so i kind of had hoped
that i would see my children that that
would be part of it it just wasn't it
was all about the afterlife and about
death i mean it was just that was what
it gave me and so because of that
um
which is fine you know i kind of went in
with it with a twofer so it didn't
necessarily you know uh you don't always
get what you want right but i did have
this very profound
experience surrounding the idea of death
and life and
and it didn't sort of
give me uh
oh here's all the answers kind of oh
it's all tied up in a bow sort of thing
but i did have feel as though it took me
on this real
journey
into the natural world into the universe
i was in the stars i was you know very
outside of my body i felt and
i don't know i felt very at peace with
this sort of natural
churn of the universe i guess is the
only way i can put it a sort of blender
of
you know we we are all from this stuff
we are going back to this stuff we are
all
kind of recycled around in this
big cosmic blender and there was
something about that that felt really
big
and
very
even though it seems kind of scary to
hear that to feel that it felt very
reassuring in a way
um have you seen the series how to
change your mind by michael poland that
just came out i haven't i've heard it's
great yeah well it goes into a lot of
that and like psilocybin is one of those
um really key medicines that a lot of
people take when they're have cancer and
it's terminal and they have like
complete peace with with death after
that because they see that it's not that
the nature of reality is not limited to
what we see
um with our eyes
in this reality that we're in it's
there's so much more and
um that it's there's more of a
continuation and that the the universe
is
really like quite is like all love and
connected and that they have a real
peace with it so
interesting i think it's interesting to
talk about these things because was it a
positive experience for you
yeah i mean my life changed a lot after
you know yeah
yeah yeah i mean my great my great
lesson was
um having like an
an idea that a relationship is supposed
to be this super like perfect balance
someone comes in and and my lesson was
that it wasn't gonna come from someone
else it was gonna be with myself and
then i had to die to this idea that it
was gonna i was gonna find some perfect
mate it was really me
oh that was that sucked
yeah but it's a big lesson right it's a
big lesson i'm still i mean it's still
an integral like you say it sticks with
you so you know it's funny when i went
down there
and i spoke and because i was again
doing it for a show as well so we did a
lot of interviews with the people that
were working down there and this in this
camp you know down in the amazon and one
of the things that they said is that
one of the worst
if if they kind of statistically look at
the people who come there they said that
most couples who come as a couple
don't fare well that like
most couples that go there and they're
like we want to understand our
relationships and that they end with one
of them saying i'm out of here you know
like it that that that people looking
for those answers in someone else often
come away with this experience that it's
something that they have to deal with
themselves that they have yeah
so that's that's a common that's a
common part of that story yeah yeah well
i just think you know you got all these
places and there's so many other
modalities to
um growth and evolution and knowing more
i mean these i mean
medicine ceremonies are common all over
the world in different ways and through
different
different means but um but they're but
they're they're very common and um
that's the great thing about travel is
getting exposure to some of that stuff
and you know uh learning more about how
to grow and expand i think fundamentally
um just like the universe is growing and
expanding i think our purpose is to grow
and expand what do you think what do you
think our purpose is to being here well
like that that kind of brings us full
circle to what we started in the
beginning like when i when i look back
at the history of all these
civilizations and you see
at least at the kind of big level you
you see conflict power struggles
you know overreaching of these
civilizations and of course there's all
these individual stories that are lost
underneath all that of just regular
folks but i do think that
i think our function here if i mean i
don't know if there is a function but i
think the best use of our time
is to be
present
and to love and to care for people and
to do all those things that are kind of
hard to do because we do all get swept
up in our careers and our
responsibilities and our jobs and and
the fact that life is hard it is every
day there are things that are
frustrating for all of us and difficult
and so
i don't know to me that's the big lesson
i look at all these tombs and all these
people it doesn't matter whether you
were
um an eight-year-old girl or whether you
were the pharaoh
um we're all going the same way and so
one of the things the lessons that i
look i'm someone who
i'm
i work too much i'm hard on myself i've
driven i have a lot of things i want to
do i'm always on the move i have a lot
of responsibilities you might know what
some of those things are like um you
have a lot i was like
yeah
and
and and so and those things do bring me
joy like i i don't like not doing
anything like i don't think there's
anything wrong with that stuff right but
it is also the case that you can just
get sort of swept up in the stress of
all of that and just get swept up in the
the grind of it all and so for me i
think
the the big lesson for me is to look at
all those people and to realize
you know what a gift that we're alive at
this moment and what a gift that we're
here at all you know cosmically that
we're just here so i try to remember
every day to sort of take a deep breath
and think about all those civilizations
and places that have come and gone and
how important all those things were and
now they're just gone
and to think okay
that what's really important is just
that we're here and we're here and now
and so have a good day you know i mean i
know that sounds so trite in a way but i
really do think it is kind of like
be good be happy when you can
um and generally don't be an [ __ ] you
know i mean that's kind of i think what
we're aiming for here yeah well sweet
jordan peterson says we don't get away
with anything in life so
yeah with that in mind you gotta you
know you do your do your best um that's
right all right well then to wrap it up
um and let you go and let you get on
with the rest of your vacation thank you
for talking to me during um are you
kidding it's great my i'm my my my kids
are probably thrilled i'm not chasing
after them they're eating ice cream
right now
totally they're with their grandparents
they're eating way too much ice cream at
this very moment for sure
before dinner um so you at the beginning
to bring it back around you you know
traveling and doing all the things that
you do and
you know as you said uh
wanting to accomplish things and being
hard on yourself and going going going
uh you also said at the beginning that
you can't do this forever so
if you can't do this forever do you have
ideas about what it is that you'll do um
after i mean you have the show you have
the tonight show i'm calling it the
tonight show uh the josh gates tonight
show which i went on which was really
fun
so you know is it transitioning into
that or what other things come to mind
and what kind of timeline do you feel
like you can uh gallivant around the
world and and are you running out of
spots to stop at
well definitely not running out of spots
to stop at there's no shortage of
mysteries in the world which is great i
mean
this is one of those things i might be
opening a can of worms here because i
have questions for you about this too
but it's like
you know i have such a unique job that
it's like i'm this travel guy i've been
all over the world i'm a presenter i'm a
host
i i could probably do a lot of different
things right like and there are so many
things i think i'd like to do um i would
like to
travel and tell stories and tell
different kinds of stories and do
different kinds of shows and uh i'd love
to write more i'd love to
run a travel company i'd love to lead
tours i'd love to be a teacher i don't
know i'd love to do a million things um
and
and i'm fortunate in that i could
probably steer towards some of those
things and have a good chance of of
doing them and having them maybe be
successful
and that's almost enough rope to hang
yourself with because you kind of go
you know what what do you do like you
don't want to do too many things at once
because then you kind of end up
just in this cloud of like i'm not
really committed to any of these things
and we we both probably kind of know a
little bit what that's like and
but i also feel like there's so many
things i'm interested in that i don't
just want to go down one road and say
that's what i'm going to do
so i don't know is the answer i mean i
know that um
that
i'm pretty good at when the time when i
don't want to do something anymore i'm
pretty good at being like i'm going to
stop doing this you know i still have
something
yeah
yeah i mean i have no
qualm being like just putting down the
thing and going that's that's it like
i'm good like i'm good with this i'm
moving on to something else like i can
do that and not be too scared of that
you know
but i do feel like i still love what i'm
doing i still love the show and
traveling the world
i know that i want to spend more time
with my kids in the future so i know
there's another gear i have to find
somewhere to allow for that
but i don't know i mean
this is one of the things i haven't
figured out which is like
i do have this
fomo kind of like not fear of missing
out but fear of missing opportunity
that it's like
yeah that's a new fomo i love that right
yeah like like this this this fear of
like
oh what if i should be doing this other
thing right yeah like taking the
opportunities that you have and not let
like letting them fall by the wayside
just because
right why
so i don't know i have that kind of
thing that that nags at me but i also
kind of feel like i'm where i'm supposed
to be and i'm and i'm i love the show
and i love my work at discovery and it's
been great and so
i don't know i think that time will tell
and i i hope
that those
changes will be apparent for me it's
like oh i should do this you know but
maybe they won't be maybe it'll be a
hard decision to make what if you did a
travel show with your kids
i would love that
where would you take them first where
would you take them first where's the
first like best place to take your kids
for total adventure
ah just like the coolest place
i don't have kids i know a lot of people
that do
i
i so it's tough right like like kids are
little kids especially my because my
kids are six and four they're quite
young
they're wowed by
you know they're wowed by going to a
hotel because there's an elevator i know
they're like they're wowed by anything
water parks are like a threat but indoor
water park is is heaven for a child like
that's all they care about you know i
think when my kids are a little older
i would like to take them somewhere that
um
showcases to them kind of like when i
was a kid going over to england
that the world is a big interesting
place with a lot of incredible history
to it i mean i i love the idea of
vacations that are kind of a fusion of
giving kids the stuff they like and the
water slide in the pool and all that but
also being able to really go
somewhere meaningful like i love the
yucatan in mexico for that reason like
yeah totally no i mean forget cancun but
like you go to a resort for a few days
and have a really nice experience and
then you could get in a jeep and you
could drive a couple hours inland and
you can be in the middle of the maya
world oh yeah
these incredible ruins and i mean
chichen itza i finally went there this
recently but i mean there's so many cool
ruins to see in mexico so many so you
know it'll be something like that and
and i i also
you know i'm a big believer
not so much with little kids but like
i'm a really big believer when it comes
to traveling
that
travel should challenge us on some level
you know like i think we are so stressed
out about the idea of vacationing and
wanting our trips and i get that like we
all want to relax and we're all
overworked and and we get in america we
get less vacation time than most
industrialized nations but like i do
think that
when you think back on the things that
you really remember
from traveling if i said like what's you
know if if you pin someone down and you
say tell me an incredible thing that
happened to you when you were traveling
they'll probably tell you about a
misadventure
or something that was like like
everything went sideways and we got
caught in this
that's what i always do when something
goes wrong it's like
my haley who's been with me for so long
she's like she gave me that line many
many many many years ago and she was
like making memories and it is truly
what you remember is the [ __ ] it is
because you're challenged and maybe
you're a little scared and you're up
against something so whenever i travel
anywhere it's always i always tell
people if they're planning a trip
okay go on vacation sit by the pool do
your thing right but you've got to go
every couple days or every or at least
once on your trip you've got to do
something
that
scares you that gets you off the resort
that like you don't know if you're going
to be good at
whatever it is volunteers don't know if
it's going to be good or not who cares
yes
take a cooking class like i don't know
do something where you're like going to
be challenged by something yeah that's
great advice and that's the only thing
you'll remember
it really is like
you know like i think about because i
live in la for most of the year like i
think about vegas right like i've been
to vegas a million times because
you live in la it's you know it's close
right so especially when i was first in
la we would drive out to vegas all the
time right we were broke and we you know
you go for the weekend get some cheap
you know 89 a night uh hotel somewhere
and um and sleep on top of the sheets
exactly um exactly but like most of
those trips
they all kind of blend together you know
you're like you don't really remember
any of them because it's just kind of
like hanging out and having a good time
and drinking and that's all great like
i'm not against any of that but like
it doesn't stick to your ribs right like
it isn't like meaningful travel so
i just think you can go to the most
beautiful place in the world and sit by
a pool and in three years you'll barely
be able to remember it but if you
you know go on some excursion and get
stuck in the mud and have to push your
jeep and you know whatever you'll be
talking about forever so
i want my kids to go to fun places but i
also want them to
make memories i want them to to like be
challenged by stuff you know so
i don't know we'll see um they'll
they'll um
we'll see how much they like pushing a
jeep in the rain
no matter what happens i guarantee
whatever whatever whatever does it will
be full of adventure and it will be
interesting you'll make many memories
and
you'll probably it'll probably be on tv
maybe maybe well hopefully all right
well if you're thinking of that show
where you want to dive into more
spiritual stuff i've been looking for
that moment that moment someone wants to
go travel around and go and really
investigate like the spiritual realm i'm
your girl
i love it i love it hey i got i got lots
of skepticism that you can that you can
disabuse me of well it's perfect it can
be like a mulder and scully and i
totally believe in it so it's like the
you know
you know wilbon and kornheiser you know
you gotta have people that like don't
agree mulder and scully i'm ready we'll
do our we'll go travel the world and
just argue with each other the entire
time
it sounds like a normal relationship
exactly exactly
all right thank you so much but it was
such a problem
totally had more questions but who cares
we're gonna we'll we'll just have to
i mean i'm gonna ask like boring ones
like what's your favorite place here and
what's the most this one and that's not
but i thought i think we talked about
way more fun stuff great i look forward
to the next chat
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the subscribe button